[Musique]
la lunette de soleil c'est vraiment un
accessoire extrêmement commun pour pas
avoir le soleil dans les yeux et le fait
de ne pas percevoir le regard de la
femme je crois que c'est justement c'est
un côté très mystérieux et et donc oui
ça doit être c'est un côté très
sensuel
l'aspect fondamental des lunettes noires
c'est le refus de la transparence c'est
le refus d'une
communication amoureuse qui soit
[Musique]
directeak
raconter l'histoire des lunettes de
soleil c'est osé affronter cet astre en
fusion ICAR s'y est brûlé les ailes
depuis bien longtemps déjà l'homme lui
est parvenu à le regarder en face mais
il n'en est pas resté là et les solaires
sont devenus multiples accessoires de
mode ou protectiontion médicale
initialement conçu pour protéger les
yeux elles sont souvent en fait
utilisées pour préserver une intimité
afin d'analyser la sémantique des
lunettes de soleil leur évolution et
leur fonction laissons la parole au plus
grand
spécialistes
les lulettes noires c'était tout de même
l'emblème des aveugles et de fait ce
sont les gens voyants qui se sont
accaparés cet objet lunette noire un
objet qui au départ était réservé à un
infirme à quelque chose
handicap donc l'aveugle est devenu un
objet qui est qui a glissé qui a évolué
vers l'extrême l'opposé ES S de pas
tromper d'adress l'apparence parfois le
kit mais quelque chose de
[Musique]
trèsentatoire il y a une espèce
d'obsession dans les lunettes noires qui
serait
un emblème de star encore aujourd'hui et
qu'il faut à tout prix avoir pour
montrer qu'on a réussi merci merci
beaucoup les lunettes les lunettes c'est
le sésame du
Paradis vous les
mettez dehors il fait gris vous mettez
vos lunettes et vous passez dans le
canivau vous voyez comme des dauphins
qui
[Musique]
sautent les lunettes traduisent une
expansion extraordinaire des loisirs et
un accès au loisirs et au sport
prodigieux les lunettes c'est à la fois
lié au corps à l'esprit à l'affectif à
l'émotionnel le soleil il est il est
dans la tête non je vois l'aventure des
lunettes de soleil a commencé voici 20
siècle avant de devenir l'objet que nous
connaissons c'est-à-dire des vers
colorés maintenus grâce à une monture
les protections solaire revêit de
multiples formes ainsi au Moyen-Âge il
pouvait s'agir de voiles noires dont les
pèlerins couvraent leur visage afin de
protéger leurs yeux lorsqu'il
traversaient les montagnes partons à la
découverte des ancêtres des
[Musique]
soleils les ancêtres les plus célèbres
des solaires ont été inventés par les
tribus inuites afin de se protéger des
fortes réflexions du soleil sur la neige
les tribus indigènes taillaient dans un
os d'étroites fentes qui réduisaient la
quantité de lumière frappant l'œil
l'intérieur
éend de su mélang à de l'huile ou de la
poudre à fus qui neutralis les
réflexions du soleil le principe de ces
lunette éta identique à celui de la
meurtrière l'il étant près de la fente
son champ de vision n'était pas
restreint
[Applaudissements]
mais la véritable histoire des lunettes
de soleil est indissociable de celle
plus générale des lunettes de vue les
découvertes et les innovations techni
aussi bien dans le domaine des veres que
dans celui des montures seront appliqués
aux lunettes de correction comme aux
lunettes
solaires les lunettes terme désignant
des vers enchassés dans une monture sont
apparu pour la première fois dans une
illustration au 14e siècle en Italie
elles étaient alors réservées à une
élite religieuse ou bourgeoise les
montures ont évolué à travers les
siècles en fonction des modes et des
progrès de la technologie les premières
branches sont apparues à la cour de
Louis XV
il s'agissait des lunettes à tempe ainsi
appelé parce qu'elles n'atteignaient pas
les oreilles afin de ne pas se prendre
dans les perruques qui étaient alors
portées par la suite elle a forme des
montures à vari des face à main au
[Musique]
pinceenez l'industrialisation du 19e
siècle a imposé la nécessité de libérer
les mains des travailleurs les branches
des lunettes ont alors pris une
importance
accrue au 20e siècle siècle l'arrivée
des plastiques a laissé libre cours à
l'imagination des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
designers l'histoire des lunettes
solaires est étroitement lié à la prise
de conscience de la nécessité de se
protéger contre les méfets du soleil le
soleil sur l'œil a un effet très mauvais
quand il est à forte dose exactement
comme pour la peau il peut donner des
lésions importantes tout d'abord sur les
pièr brûler les paupières deuxièmement
sur la cornée donner des brûlures
superficielles de ces de cette cornée
avec des douleurs intenses et ce qui se
passe lorsqu'on a passé toute la journée
à la neige sans protection troisièmement
à l'intérieur de l'œil sur le cristalin
qui est la petite lentille transparente
qu'on a l'intérieur de l'œil favoriser
le développement de cataracte donc qui
est une maladie et enfin sur la rétine
la petite membrane qui est au fond de
l'œil qui reçoit les images peut-être
accéléré la formation d'une
dégénérescence d'une dégénérescence
rétinienne tous les enfants qui naissent
naissent avec des yeux bleus et puis au
bout de quelques mois certains yeux
deviennent progressivement plus ou moins
marrons alors vous avez tous les teintes
le bleu clair bleu foncé vert et puis
marron clair marron foncé en effet chez
un certain nombre d'enfants il se dépose
secondairement une couche de pigment sur
l'iris l'iris qui est une petite
membrane qui permet à la lumière de
rentrer plus ou moins à l'intérieur de
l'œil ce réglage étant automatique donc
des personnes qui auront un iris bleu
c'est très joli mais c'est un peu plus
fragile par rapport à une personne qui a
des yeux marron où il y a ce même iris
bleu recouvert par une couche de pigment
marron qui va donc mieux protéger contre
les effets de la lumière trop
[Musique]
forte
c'est à l'Antiquité qu' est pour la
première fois fait mention d'une
protection solaire l'ancien dans son
hisoria natural que est le plus simpley
deoser nontilal pourser les combats de
gladiateur par la suite l'amélioration
des techniques de travail du ver
permettra de substituer le ver coloré à
la pierre
semiprécieuse
c'est en Orient que ces techniques se
perfectionnent les vers fumés appelés
aussi pierres à thé sont utilisés par
les mandarin souhaitant paraître plus
impénétrable lorsqu'ils rendent leur
[Musique]
jugement retournons en Occident où nous
assistons à la fin du Moyen-Âge à une
prise de conscience accrue de la
nécessité de protéger ses yeux les
protéger du soleil du vent mais aussi
d'une façon qui peut paraître
surprenante aujourd'hui de la maladie
ainsi cors de de la peste de 1619 que
sont apparus pour la première fois des
lunettes prophylactiques en effet on
craignait que le regard ne soit un
vecteur de contamination ces lunettes
venaient s'intégrer à un costume de
protection dont l'idée et la réalisation
dataient du
Moyen-Âge au 17e siècle les lunettes
pourvues de verre coloré prennent le nom
de conserve ou lunette conservatrice le
verre était à l'époque la couleur
considérée comme étant la plus reposante
au milieu du 19e siècle n'est un grand
engouement pour la montagne dicté par
des raisons scientifiques l'observation
de la nature par exemple ou pour des
raisons médicales notamment le
thermalisme on assiste à l'apparition de
nouvelles pratiques telles l'alpinisme
ou le ski ces nouvelles pratiques
exigent de nouvelles protections ce
seront les premières lunettes de glacier
les innovations techniques développées
pour les sportifs de haut niveau
deviendront rapidement accessibles au
grand public c'est là une première
facette de l'histoire des lunettes
solaires au 20e siècle elle va s'écrire
grâce à des opticiens et des sportifs en
associant
différents produits de verre et de
traitement j'ai trouvé que il y avait un
verre qui est une composition qui avait
une absorption exceptionnelle et donc ce
verre là on l'a mis en fabrication nous
étions en 1960 et ces lunettes étaient
offertes au sportifs français qui
concouraient pour les Jeux Olympiques
quand quand j'ai mis ces lunettes j'ai
tout de suite été frappé par
le par les qualités de vision de
visibilité et de protection qu'elles
apportaient Jean Burnet prend le
départ jusqu'à l'arrivée il réalise une
course merveilleuse qui lui vaut le
titre de champion olympique pourquoi
sont-ell appeler les vernis ben parce
que l'histoire a commencé en 60 et qu'en
60 c'est moi qui ai gagné qui a eu le
titre olympique de la descente en même
temps j'étais j'étais un propagandiste
enthousiaste quand je quand je suis
rentré en France j' tout fier d'arborer
mes lunettes qui portaiit pas encore mon
nom les joies du triomphe ffar en tête
sont réservés aun qui revient chez lui à
Morzine en pitoresque équipage j'étais
un jour au cinéma avec des amis et dans
les actualités
cinématographiques il y avait la
descente olympique de scallet et
jeanvnet vainqueur montant sur le podium
jeanvernet après son interview fait une
stration sur les pistes de ski avec avec
les lunettes qui qui venaient de notre
production il voit ses lunettes il dit
mes lunettes ça m'a fait plaisir bien
sûr de voir les lunettes qui qui
sortaient de mes mains les voir porter
par un champion olympique et donc j'en
ai parlé le lendemain matin à Roger
Pouillou qui était mon patron qui le
soir même est allé voir ses actualités
et mod lendemain matin ce serait bien si
on pouvait utiliser le nom de vnet sur
ces lunettes voilà comment une rencontre
entre un concepteur de verre et un
sportif a donné naissance à une grande
marque de lunettes solaire C
extraordinaire de penser que aux
États-Unis on disait on disait plus il
fait beau aujourd'hui on disait war day
today et puis après vous sa leur manie
de de de resserrer
les
to et c'était une contraction de vny
c'est c'est c'est assz c'est assez
[Musique]
extraordinaire l'histoire de vunaet est
un exemple parfait de la façon dont les
lunettes de soleil ont su conquérir un
vaste public la pratique du ski se
démocratise et l'accessoire réservé à
une élite devient un objet porté par
tous les sportifs du moniteur de ski au
champion olympique jouent un rôle
d'ambassadeur et les lunettes séduisent
le grand public qui s'approprie et
détourne l'objet une c'est pour mettre
sur la tête et une autre c'est pour
mettre sur les yeux comme
[Musique]
ça les nouveaux loisirs entraînent la
création de nouvelles marques qui surf
sur la mode des sports extrêmes en
s'associant à ces pratiques nouvelles et
à l'image de sportif renommé ell
réussissent à tou
JEE et à se faire une place sur le
marché de la solaire cyclist sur ADEP du
VTT sont autant de représentants
potentiel le citadain enofant une paire
de lunett identique à celle porté par
ses sportifs de l'extrême achète lui
aussi sa part de
rêve et de
[Musique]
risque bucks but anyway
um I've bought a lot of pairs of
sunglasses other than these but I've
paid like $200 for them i've lost them
in about the first 2 weeks after I got
them these sunglasses are classes my
work Sunnis and I call them my old
faithfuls because like I just can't lose
them like I I throw them around I take
them to the beach I try and lose them
and I just can't lose them like I you
know like I just i just don't really
care about them and I just can't lose
them that's why they W my old faifuls
but you know I can't get rid of them as
much as I try I just can't get rid of
mais les sorts des lunettes de soleil
s'inscrit surtout en parallèle avec
celui des
[Musique]
vacances le 20e siècle en effet voit
naître les congés payés les famille
découvre la plage la mer et par
conséquent la nécessité de se protéger
les
[Musique]
yeux
la démocratisation massive des vacances
entraîne une consommation en masse des
lunettes dès cette époque afin de
contrer la prolifération des lunettes de
mauvaise qualité qui ne protègent
aucunement les yeux des normes
réglementaires sont
[Musique]
établies et aujourd'hui qu'en
est-il les lunettes solaires sont
toujours associé au
à la plage au sport à la
détente mais n'est-ce pas également une
histoire de
[Musique]
couple and then I didn't like them soen
i them
back
howlasses so now we're looking for a che
pair we're actually going to buy pair
right now
si l'essentiel des recherches concerne
la meilleure protection ou le design le
plus esthétique les lunettiers ne
devrai-il pas également réfléchir à la
lunette incassable et impossible à
[Musique]
perdre
un peu de soleil des vacances des
pratiques
démocratisées voilà les ingrédients
d'une première histoire des lunettes de
soleil mais cette histoire comporte une
autre facette dans laquelle les
ambassadeurs des solaires ne sont pas
des adeptes des sports de haute montagne
mais des aviateurs et des stars de
cinéma
cette histoire débute elle aussi au 20e
siècle avec l'apparition des premiers
avions et les premières
voitures les pilotes étai alors
particulièrement exposés aux agressions
du soleil ou des poussières c'est dans
ce contexte que naî une célèbre marque
de lunett de
soleil before was based on the request
of the American military Air Force to
have a lens able to protect the eyes of
the aviators when flying at high
altitudes Bos lomba created this lens
that was called antiglare but the name
antiglare was too general so in 1937
they decided to name this lens and of
course the frame that was containing the
lens rban the first style that it's in
the memory of of this brand is the what
has been called the Aviator which is
this style uh the frame is in metal and
the classic color is gold so the Aviator
was the the first style and actually
still worldwide in the top 10 uh styles
sold nowadays Raven developed other
styles but they were used only for
military needs after the Second World
War the economic and social situation
started to change so prosperity and
fashion started to become very important
and what happened at the same time was
the world of Hollywood started to be
very relevant to all the population so
in 1961 breakfast at Tiffany which is a
very famous movie see Audrey haw wearing
one of the Raban styles which is ran
wayfirer he was born on the on the face
of
that in that movie
basically ran to become and to explode
in the market as the best sulasses that
you could have and in this year Rayan
started then to become not only a
technical sunglasses but really fashion
tool to wear the collaboration with
Hollywood didn't end with breakfast
breakfast at Tiffany we have a man in
black we have the Blues Brothers that
des pilotes d'avion nous passons donc au
starlywooden nouvell ambassadri des
lunettes de soleil évoluant au sein
d'une énorme machine
[Musique]
commerciale mot for fashion for a very
long time once you have the creation of
a star system and the star system really
develops in the period 1910 12
14 American men and women start looking
at stars as as these these these people
who are in some sense greater than they
are and they start not only looking at
them and being fascinated with them but
Wan to emulate them and especially
emulate their dress so from that point
on there
is Hollywood very consciously is
creating fashions and you what what you
have for example is is costume designers
who are not only designing costumes but
are designing fashion lines right along
with it which are then sold off the rack
in department stes in the 1920s already
all phases American allases of American
consumer culture are very definitely
influenced by Hollywood movies and there
is indeed I would say very much a
symbitic relationship between the two
that one drives the other and product
placement begins in the 20s and is goes
up until today and in fact today product
placement
becomesilmes
production
ils viennent ici il nous disent on
voudrait des lunettes de star on le dit
oui alors c'est ce qu'il vous faut ce
qu'il vous faut Sete alors je sais pas
qui a porté cell si c'est Jennifer Lopez
ou c'est C voilà donc c'est la SK de
chrisan Dior qui a fait un ravage qui
est porté par les hommes et les femmes
Tom CR qui a faitorté des belles
lunettes dur aussi et que les gens
voulaient éventuellement voir cette
paire vous avez par exemple le film
Matrix man black ils ont tous m black
sur sur les rebanes et film Matrix sur
les blind donc ça ça a quand même une
une relation cette seconde histoire des
lunettes de soleil est donc engendrée
par le désir de trroquer son statut
d'anonyme contre celui de star de fouler
un jour un tapis rouge sous les flash
des photographes les lunettes de soleil
sont considérées comme un attribut
indispensable de ce monde de paillettes
sinon comme le Césame même de ce paradis
au-delà de la protection médicale c'est
avant tout le mimétisme qui est le
moteur de l'histoire des solaires un
miroir où se réfléchissent stars et
grand public à l'image du reflet qui se
crée dans le ver des
[Musique]
solaires on
very
Madex
[Musique]
découvrons à présent les secrets de
fabrication de ces lunettes pour cela
nous allons traverser les Alpes afin de
nous rendre à agordau où se trouve la
plus grande usine de lunettes
solaire ici se pense et secré les
nouveaux modèles on y conçoit TR
nouveaux modèles par jour
[Musique]
l'immense usine du groupe luxotica
véritable ville perdue au milieu des
montagnes produit 60000 paires de
lunettes par
[Musique]
jour
pour certaines montures pas moins de 176
étapes sont
[Musique]
nécessaires une fois assemblé les
montures sont galvanisées en étant
plongé dans des bains successifs chaque
jour plus d'un kil disparaît dans cette
[Musique]
opération les montures en plastique
quant à elle sont moulées par
injection 3000 employés fabriquent ainsi
dans l'usine d'Agordo pour plus de 20
marques différentes de reban Chanel en
passant par Versace ou
[Musique]
Bulgarie ce travail qualité et d'une
précision extrême permet de produire des
lunettes fiables et robustes qui
permettront au consommateurs d'affronter
les agressions du
[Musique]
soleil les lumières sont très
différentes dans leur effet néfaste tout
d'abord il y a des lumières qu'on ne
voit pas ce sont les infrarouge et les
ultraviolets les ultraviolets sont les
plus mauvais ensuite la première
longueur d'onde visible qui est néfaste
pour l'œil c'est le bleu c'est pour ça
qu'il n'est pas très souhaitable de
mettre des Verts teintés bleus qui ne
filtrent pas du tout le bleu il est
préférable évidemment de mettre des vert
teinté qui filtreront toutes les
couleurs pareil de façon à obtenir une
égalisation vous avez dans ce cadre le
gris ou certaines formes de brun
maintenant vous pouvez avoir intérêt à
filtrer par exemple pour un
tennisman qui veut filtrer le le brun de
la de son terrain de tennis à mettre des
des lunettes bleues c'est l'exception un
petit peu il va mieux voir sa balle pour
un joueur de golf par exemple il est
indiqué de porter des lunettes roses le
rose en effet va permettre d'effacer un
petit peu le verre du champ de de golf
et permettra de mieux voir là aussi la
balle vous avez ensuite les myopes les
myopes qui vont beaucoup mieux
être mieux parce que ça va leur
rapprocher les images avec une couleur
brun allant sur le rouge les à l'inverse
les hypermétropes qui portent des vers
donc qui sont des petites loupes seront
mieux avec des vers filtrants qui sont
verts de nombreuses évolutions
techniques ont présidé à la fabrication
des différents types de verr Venise en a
été longtemps le théâtre en effet la
cité lacustre était un port de commerce
tourné vers l'Orient d'où elle importait
des techniques novatrices
[Musique]
forte de la maîtrise de la fabrication
du verre Venise a réussi à en conserver
le monopole pendant plusieurs
siècles le verre se fabrique à partir de
sable fin du silice porté à fusion pour
le teinter on y ajoute différents oxydes
de
[Musique]
métau aujourd'hui le ver des lunettes
n'est bien sr plus soufflé
artisanalement il est moulé
industriellement selon une courbe
définie puis il est surfacé avec un
grain de plus en plus fin pour obtenir
un verre au face parallèle qui ne
déformera pas
[Musique]
l'image les veres sont ensuite taillés
suivant la forme des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
montures
certains reçoivent pour finir un
traitement antireflet qui consiste à y
imposer une fine couche de métau par
évaporation dans une cloche
sousv ces différents traitements
permettent de fabriquer des verres qui
nous en font voir de toutes les couleurs
en 95 très exactement c'estàd fin 94
notre cadeau de fin d'année je sais pas
si ça peut vous amuser 94 notre cadeau
de fin d'année ça avait été bon un peu
un gadget mais cétait 95 voyez la vie en
couleur on avait trouvé ça très mignon
et la plus simple la vie en rose mais on
pouvait effectivement voir la vie en
Violet la vie en bleu la vie en jaune et
la vie en
vert un
peu un peu gadget
mais pour moi la lunette de soleil dans
la façon d'établir une
protection dans un lieu public lorsqu'on
est vêtu les légèrement pour établir une
protection c'est la lunette de soleil ça
ça m'est apparu à un moment donné où que
ce soit un accessoire qu'on se met dans
les cheveux ou qu'on a autour du cou ou
qu'on a devant soi c'est une barrière
entre soi et le public le deuxième rôle
d'une lunette de soleil dans
l'habillement dans le look d'une dans le
look d'une femme c'est réellement un
rôle tout à fait comparable au
maquillage mais alors un maquillage qui
vient par-dessus le maquillage de même
que pour moi le le maquillage fait
partie d'un loup
et exprime une idée de mode c'est un le
maquillage est déjà un accessoire de
mode alors la lunette encore plus moi je
trouve que les femmes ont plus intérêt
d'ailleurs à trouver des coloris de
monture qui aillent avec leurs cheveux
avec leurs teint comme le maquillage que
uniquement avec le vêtement c'est un
moyen de se jouer les rôles c'est un
accessoire comme au théâtre finalement
se jouer le rôle de la vampe ou se jouer
le rôle de
l'intellectuel c'est vrai qu'avant la
lunette de soleil avait un peu une vie
autonome même si elle suivait mais avec
des cycles de vie beaucoup plus large
aujourd'hui on est vraiment sur sur un
accessoire de mode qui suit les mêmes
cycles de vie produits qu'un qu'un
vêtement et et donc avec des des des des
tendances très très très très courtes et
qui se renouvellent de plus en plus vite
on achète maintenant d'ailleurs des des
montures griffé c'est cétait c'est ce
qui a beaucoup changé c'est que c'est à
voir à quel point les les couturiers et
les créateurs et les marques se sont
rendus compte que c'éit un accessoire au
même titre et même plus important qu'un
foulard par exemple ou que ou qu'un
enfin un colis on peut pas le griffer
tandis que la lunette on peut on peut la
griffer la mode c'est d'être comme tout
le monde mais malgré tout la femme veut
être unique le moyen justement d'être
tout le monde tout en étant unique c'est
ce ce cultivver dans le cadre des des
tendances de la mode son look àelle la
lunette de soleil joue un rôle à peu
près aussi important que le sac un rôle
qui est à la fois utilitaire et en même
temps générateur de de la personnalité
d'un
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
宿所
結今気る がァッョ が
8年代 7年代
の
[Applaudissements]
W
入っ てる
んける ちょっと い ん です けど ちょっと
[Applaudissements]
感 these sunglasses i have to admit are
really cheap they're only about 30 bucks
I do have a very expensive pair which I
bought in New York about 4 weeks ago
which cost the earth and I thought W
yeah they do W i'm not taking these away
on holiday because i'll probably snap
them or l them so how much did your
sunglasses cost in the States um about
American you don't tell people because
how do you
feel
depuis que le monde de la mode s'est
emparé des lunettes solaires l'évolution
de ces dernières s'est prodigieusement
accélérée mais les prochaines
innovations découleront plutôt d'apport
technologiques que de facteurs
esthétiques à l'image du téléphone
portable à quand les lunettes solaires
appareil photo des pistes de réponse
peuvent être trouvé dans les
laboratoires de recherche de l'armée
souvent pionniers en matière
d'innovation technologique voici donc
présenter le l'équipement du combattant
débarqué qui préfigure l'équipement Féin
le fantassin à liaison
intégrée donc on a un certain nombre
d'équipements de protection sur le
fantassin un casque bien sûr et puis une
visière de protection elle a été étudiée
pour résister au chocs donc aux impacts
balistiques au chocs de Pierre elle peut
également être hermétique en cas de
tempête de sable dans le désert et puis
étant donné qu'on a une forte menace
laser et une prolifération des armes
lasers sur le champ bataille elle a
également un dispositif antilaser donc
des filtres qui permettent d'éliminer
les fréquences qui vont être les plus
nocifs pour l'œil l'équipement comprend
également des lunettes de protection
c'est des équipements qui sont
modulaires on peut y adjoindre également
une fonction protection solaire donc
elles peuvent faire à la fois office de
lunette de vue lunette de protection
solaire et lunett de protection laser
contre une certaine gamme de fréquence
car on peut pas tout mettre en même
temps protéger contre toutes ces toutes
ces menaces en même temps sinon ça
serait tellement opaque que le
combattant ne verrait plus rien dans la
plupart des
[Musique]
situations l'équipement est relié au
fusil par l'intermédiaire de de ce câble
qui
envoie sur le visuel de tête situé
ici les images qui sont données par
cette
caméra
voici la la jumelle lucide qui permet
une vision monoculaire ou binoculaire
monoculaire en mode vidéo ou binoculaire
en mode infrarouge lunette caméra vision
nocturne projection d'information sur
les ver des lunettes autant de
techniques déjà existantes à quand leur
transfert sur des lunettes solaires
destiné au grand public et qui aura les
moyens de se les
offrir
voyage au cœur du désert dans l'oasis
doré de Palm Springs en Californie où se
donne en spectacle ce que la richesse
permet
[Musique]
d'acheter
there's still a lot of Ray coming
through those clouds so even then we
have to go ahead and wear our sunglasses
some of my customers have wardrobe of
glasses you change your shirt you change
your shoes you change sunglasses with
every outfit we have particular
customers that uh they like one frame
and they want the lenses in just all
different colors so when she wears a
different outfit she can wear the same
the same frame but a different color
something like this is about
50 when I saw this I had to go ahead and
have this piece good protection it gives
you no sunl from up above and a nice
wrap it's a very
um a piece that you always be talking
about it is just like a piece of art and
what it is is you have a special piece
and you won't see
yourself wearing it or going down to the
market or anywh to a party that two
people are going to go ahead and have
the same frame so this is why it is like
a piece of art I did sell a Carti frame
which was encrusted with diamonds and
emeralds for
[Musique]
8,000 in the
[Rires]
[Musique]
background maybe I should have invested
sunglasses are the sort of thing you
lose though they are so I think if you
you're bound to lose them if you pay too
much money
[Musique]
for thank
you
les lunettes solaires se sont finalement
bien éloignées du myth d'Icar à tel
point qu''est apparu la mode des
lunettes solaires porté la
nuit je crois que c'est une très
mauvaise chose porter des vertés la nuit
la nuit l'œil a besoin de voir l'œil a
besoin d'une certaine luminosité et
lorsque l'on porte des vertinés il faut
que cela soit absolument nécessaire ce
qu'on a vu apparaître récemment ce sont
tous les vers légèrement teintés en fait
les vers qui étaient plus du tout foncés
qui étaient des teinté de façon assez
claire assez subtile puis que justement
c'était des lunettes qu'on commençait à
porter pour pour sortir en discothèque
et l'origine de ces lunettes de soleil
bon c'est c'est c'est c'est c'est
l'origine de ces lunettes de soleil en
fait qu'on mettait pour sortir en
discothèque enfin qu'on met pour sortir
en discothèque c'est simplement pour
cacher la pupille quand on quand on
passe le le le passage du du portier en
boîte donc et cass chez la pupille c'est
pour une bonne raison c'est pour montrer
qu'on n pas pris de stupéfiant nous
avons besoin d'avoir un CYC régulier
entre les périodes de veille et de
sommeil si nous avons trop souvent des
lunettes teintées nous risquons d'avoir
des troubles de ce rythme notre sommeil
est réglé par une petite glande la
glande pinéale et par tout un faisceau
dit southalamique à partir de la rétine
donc du fond de l'œil il y a des fibres
qui vont directement vers ce réseau et
qui soit provoque la sécrétion de
certaines hormones soit empêche la
sécrétion de ces hormones qui favoris ou
au contraire empêche le sommeil et c'est
ce cycle lumière nuit qui nous permet de
vivre normalement pour quelqu'un qui
sort qui sort la nuit il ne faut surtout
pas mettre des vertetinés il va en
prendre l'habitude il risque ensuite
d'avoir des troubles extrêmement graves
pas forcément quand il est jeune mais
quand il sera plus âgé vers les 40 50 60
ans il risque de présenter des troubles
importants à à la fois du sommeil et à
la fois au niveau de ses yeux avec des
périodes d'éblouissement qui vont
devenir carrément pathologiqu mais les
gens font des remarques surtout
n'importe quoi c'est ce que ça vaut je
veux
dire les lunettes les lunettes les
lunettes de de soleil le soir ça attire
des
commentaires les lunettes colorées je
préfère dire les lunettes colorées le
soir ça attire effectivement des
commentaires du genre il y a pas de
soleil c'est vrai qu' à Paris souvent
ENF souvent ça c'est arrivé que des gens
fassent la réflexion il y a pas de
soleil c'est dommage pour
eux où est le soleil dans la nuit bah il
est fondamentalement dans la tête des
gens ouement il est pas dans le
ciel mais mais après c'est le problème
des gens qui identifie les lunettes en
couleur au lunettes de soleil pour moi
c'est pas des lunettes de soleil c'est
des lunettes en couleur ce rose là je
veux dire c'est un produit c'est une
c'est
une c'est une formule voilà qui me
correspond que j'ai cherché que j'ai
j'ai expérimenté enfin j'ai fait des
essais avec des lentilles j'ai rajouté
les jà ce que je trouve le rose qui me
convient la couleur qui me paraît la
plus je sais pas quoi la plus proche de
la réalité
légèrement légèrement doré et Rosie
voilà légèrement réchauffé
légèrement autant voir je sais pas quoi
la réalité de la façon la plus
heureuse plutôt que je vais pas mettre
des lunettes vertes ou des lunettes
bleues qui vont plomber ma
journée bonsoir bienvenue au
[Musique]
lid voici les
loge et mes jolies lunettes que je porte
pendant un des numéros de cette nouvelle
Rev
[Musique]
bon ce numéro fait partie du prologue et
dans le dans cette revue bonheur la
première partie
euh c'est une représentation des femmes
de la femme en général et je crois que
c'est si chic c'était pour montrer le le
côté très Hollywood c'est la femme pinup
je c'est très difficile à
[Musique]
décrire fait so c'est couleurs je sais
pas c'est pourpre enfin c'est assez
c'est c'est assez clair donc c'est pas
du tout gênant sur scène avec les
éclairages en revanche c'est un petit
peu plus difficile dans les couliss
parce qu'on vient se placer en costume
avec nos plumes et tout et tout et les
lunettes et là on doit se placer dans le
noir donc là cé un petit peu plus
difficile il a fallu qu'on s'y habitue
mais sinon non c'est absolument pas
gênant je pense que ça donne un côté
mystérieux et le fait de pas voir le
regard comme ça des
[Musique]
femmes j'aime beaucoup les Verts colorés
les verts bleus voilà pour le matin pour
donner un peu meilleur mine et cacher un
peu les cernes
euh et euh voilà j'aime pour le soleil
j'aime bien quelque chose de très
couvrant et assez noir voilà pour la
nuit quelque chose de transparent donc
on peut on peut jouer avec donc c'est un
côté très sympa on peut jouer avec le
regard les baisser oui je pense
queeffectivement c'est un accessoire de
séduction
these are actually like my boyfriend
sunglasses and um yeah I met him at the
World Cup final rugby and he lives in
the UK and I live here in Sydney and
um i just loved his sunglasses and I
just had to get a pair and this is sort
of probably how I feel the connection
with us
[Applaudissements]
too
les lunettes de soleil permettent une
gestuelle qui peut fonctionner comme une
sorte de substitut du geste amoureux ou
même de de l'acte sexuel il y a une
manière de susauter les branches d'une
d'une
lunette d'essuyer les les verres de
caresser la la monture donc il y a un
aspect métaphorique évident qui dit
lunette noire dit détours dit un art de
l'oblique de quive avec les solaires
s'établit une sorte de de dialectique
entre le montrer et le cacher entre la
dissimulation et la
révélation entre le voyurisme et
l'exhibitionnisme nous sommes en fait
aux antipode d'une mythologie du regard
qui serait reflet de l'âme et ou une
mythologie des yeux reflet de de la
vérité le fait de dissimuler son regard
sert d'alibi en fait à l'exhibition du
regard on dérobe l'organe pour mieux le
mettre en valeur pour mieux le le
valoriser il y a quelques années encore
les lunettes noires signifiaient le le
méchant le le salot entre guillemets ou
bien désignait la vampe la garce la
femme fatale désigner aussi le
mafieux désignait le playboy je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ourdi le symbolisme est
beaucoup plus diffus et beaucoup plus
divers et d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
intéressant
[Musique]
merde les lunettes de soleil symbolisent
bien sûr la la star et le public va
avoir tendance à adopter des des
lunettes noires pour se créer une
identité fictive de star pour être
reconnu et ce qui est très amusant c'est
le paradoxe de l'anonymat c'est
c'estàdire que au lieu de finalement de
se cacher au lieu de rester dans dans
l'incognito et bien les lunettes noire
au contraire désigne complètement elle
démarque l'individu comme une figure de
style comme un écart et elles
apparaissent comme un signe
d'appartenance les lunettes permettent
donc d'appartenir à une famille et aucun
membre de cette famille ne doit
I theany for my dog midn you just seem
to be sensi to I triedes regular human
sunglasses they just didn't you know
they didn't really sit well on his nose
so I just started playing with the nose
bridge and finally got something that
fit him right so I take him for walks
and he's wearing his Doggles and we
named him in the mean dog goggles
Doggles you know we thought it was cute
it wasn't you know it wasn't company at
that point it was just a produ that I
made for my dog so take for walks and
people sayy where you get and say I made
them so I people started requesting them
and I started making them at night after
my regular fulltime job and then we we
decided to put up a website give people
some information and a place that they
could order them and it just just
started taking off from there the
Doggles have polycarbonate lenses so
they're shadpof they're antiog and they
have 100% UV protection they use them in
the car when they hang their head out
car window they use they going for a
walk in theght sunlight when they
hunting when theying we have peopleute
with their dogs all kinds of different
scenarios any you would put your
sunglasses on you would put your dogs
Doggles on I know we got a lot of
extraps
here
work we have a lot of different lenses
lots of different colors we have eight
different colors and then three
different patterns this is a holiday
Lens it has a bat scre on it they came
out for Halloween so it's just kind of
cute you know if you have like the glow
in the dark frames and then bat screen
down there you can wear when you'reting
a lot of people dress up the dogs for
halloween's another fancy screen Lens it
has an eye on it the eyes are opposite
so it actually looks like the dogs
wearing it looks like eyes it's like
those funny pop glasses kind ofute for
people who like to dress their
[Musique]
dogs what do you think
dude we also sent a lot of Doggles to
the World Trade Center too on 911 well
the dogs were sniffing for you know
people that were buried in the in the
World Trade Center after it collapsed
and I'm sure you heard about all the
problems that the dogs had and some of
them died and you know it was really
hard for the dogs working there
and the vets working at the Trade Center
contacted us and ask us for Doggles
because all the smoke and the dust and
everything that was there was getting in
and harming their eyes say
hi
today we've sold almost 200,000 pairs of
Doggles i know it sounds like a huge
number yeah it's amazing well sunglasses
are part of our society i think they're
a huge part of our society you know for
health reasons of course but I really
think that sunglasses are a big fashion
statement and people do take that to
their dogs you know they dogs are part
of the family these days and whatever
humans get dogs get
exort son vitrier à lui faire voir la
vie en beau des ver Ros roug bleu des
vitres Magi des vitres de paradis
disIl aujourd'hui ces vitres de paradis
sont à la porté de
tous
lettecouru long
voyage SK HW pour permettre ainsi à tout
le monde en toutes circonstances de voir
la vie en
[Musique]
beau